we have essentially a three-ring fight
between Lockwood Priscilla and Riley
we have Michael Lockwood in his own
Corner trying to take over if you will
the business of the young girls we have
Riley the daughter who really was the
one designated by Lisa Marie to take
over the um if you will the business and
then we have the mother Priscilla who's
in her own Corner trying to essentially
also take over Lisa Marie's ex skipped a
court hearing today put inside a judge
indicated he will formally be granted
full custody of 14-year-old Harper and
Finley here he is all bundled up getting
gas on Saturday next up Michael will
seek to be named the twins Guardian that
will allow him to represent their
interests in the estate battle
in another messy twist One online site
reported that Riley had the locks
changed that Graceland effectively
keeping Priscilla out of the Memphis
Mansion where she and Elvis used to live
Graceland fired back calling the report
untrue adding no locks at Graceland have
been changed since Lisa Marie's passing
Kelly Clarkson knows all about messy
Court battles it's been one year since
she settled her divorce from Brandon
Blackstock and now I won't be getting
married but like forever no
you've heard it here Kelly still pays
115 000 a month in spousal support the
couple shares joint custody of their two
kids my kids you know we split my ex and
I they three weeks with him through it's
me three weeks 10 throws me and that's a
long time to not have your babies but it
actually ended up being very helpful for
me that me time was transformative what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger
Kelly who talked to Angie Martinez's IRL
podcast credits therapy and staying busy
with helping her get through it all it
was our first season of the talk show
and we're trying to get it off the
ground it was just a lot and so I think
being busy sometimes is very helpful
um but then it was important like this
last summer like I took off and I
literally probably pissed off so many
people but I I was like I'm not doing a
thing
I have this song called red flag
collector on my next album because I
refuse to be that anymore I love my life
right now it took a minute it took some
work and I got it and I got it back
foreign